welcome back to eat see live it looks
like we'll be getting the crazy rich
Asians sequel sooner than we thought and
our own Danny direct Oh is on top of it
when it's going right Cass I got this
shot with the cast and the drug for the
film John and chew over the weekend at
the unforgettable gala the cast was
honored with the Vanguard Award and they
gave mr. tooth Best Director and that's
where I found out that not only one but
two crazy rich Asians films are brewing
check it out before I let you go I gotta
know what can you tell us about the
sequin are you and are you expected to
direct it again I would love to of
course you know in the end of this movie
we plants a little Harry Shum Jr in
there and there's some fun storylines
with Charlie that I think would be
really cool to tell but it's early days
I got to figure out it's got to work out
and scheduling scheduling and also we
got to close my deal so come on let's
get this done who in the bunch knows
anything about the sequel raise your
hand when can we expect so just still
talking about it hoping to get it
rolling later this year and has already
been reported maybe two and three will
happen back-to-back that's right don't
waste any more time folks
I love that you getting a scoop right
there actually I mean we knew that in
late August Warner Brothers said that a
sequel was in the works Michelle Yeoh
even revealed to us last week that the
script is starting to be worked on but I
get the cyntha it's gonna be a while
before we get those two films but I know
it's gonna be worth the wait good things
take time
they really do in the meantime I mean
clearly this cast is on a streak right
now they just are fresh off two Golden
Globe nominations including Best Picture
in a comedy or musical and also this
morning you guys they racked up a couple
more nominations for the Critics Choice
Awards including Best acting ensemble
Best Comedy and Best Actress in a comedy
for Constance whoo I mean Constance
making history check him the first Asian
woman to be nominated for a Golden Globe
in that category in decades the last
time an Asian woman was nominated for
lead actress in a Musical or Comedy was
1974 go collect your trophy girl
[Music]
[Applause]